what I will do today is present you a
checklist to help you steer a data
science project
um just a quick presentation my name is
Morgan mouth I I have a PhD in Material
Science I have worked a few years as
data engineer and lately I've been data
scientist at spark so not Apache
Sparkles Park is a consulting company
we are based in Dublin and in Malaga and
we are specializing data and more
specifically Bridging the Gap between
product and data okay
so what does it mean exactly uh that
means that we took the AI system
and we put that into the product context
and we make it fit the best as we can
so that that is valid for the full
timeline of a product
from preliminaries 2D to maintenance and
from all level of detail of a product
from the product itself to on a line of
corridor data point
foreign
so what I'm trying to do today is not to
tell you exactly what to do I'm just
want to give you a checklist to help you
uh
just not forgetting important stuff
uh well there is bad formatting issue
this is quietly
uh
yeah so be it
um so first why a checklist
um well I'm also a scuba diver in uh in
addition to be a data scientist and I
like checklist they helped me to not
drop into the water with my air off
so yeah checklists are nice and uh
especially in Consulting when you jump
from Project to project having processes
having checklists can help you just put
some order and put some structure into
the unknown
um
so what's the checklist exactly
so that checklist is Portillo if you
don't know what that name mean it's the
French name for who's really cool old
map as you see one example here
so it helped
um sailor travel and it will help you
navigate the project
foreign
is a project Vision that's the stuff
that gives you Direction and help you
prioritizing stuff
so what you're looking for is what
problem are you trying to solve who's
that problem or
concern
um
and if you go toward product and product
Vision you will need to add the what in
the how also
so I get that for now I'm very abstract
to so to give you a better example uh
let me present you the project of one of
our clients
um as an example and as our red line for
this talk
so fair product was a platform that was
helping retailer to
um Source manage curate and provide
brand image sequence to website
um via end-to-end solution so the
retailer don't have any difficulty to
manage that
and as for my own problem statements
that are part of it it's a curation and
the sequencing of the image and
sequences
for the second later of our organizing
this is the reminder to keep the deck
clear and the ship lock up to date
specifically to prevent knowledge leak
and to better communicate you need
processes you need documentation you
need tools and methods
so as example
um
I I'm not exhausted here because there
is way too much out there but
requirement model description
ing system that help
if you want a much better list that here
you can check the incoming standard for
AI which is the ISO
for 42001
and they have a very good on checklist
again but a better one more precise one
for all the organization and process and
document that you can need in a data
science project
so third letter r for relationship
this is a reminder that you're not alone
in a boat that you will have to
communicate with people that you your AI
system will have to interface with other
systems
and also a reminder that being kind and
to help the communication and the
interfacing
um
here a bit more detail into the AI
system that we create for that client
uh as I told you we were managing the
creation and the sequencing of images
um so we took images in the states the
brand gave them
we create them on towards standard we
then use a autoan condor to embed them
and we use the embedding
um direct
sequence of embedding comparison
to create sequences of images
and as you can see in that diagram there
is a Arrow coming from nowhere and going
nowhere
that's not really nowhere but the
overall part of the system that will be
the users that will be on the databases
that will be the Brand's ingestion
component
so
for communicating all of that I will
need to discuss with the product
managers delivery manager
the system architect the ux lead and the
qled
um four letter t for testing
that's the talk with the qng usually and
that's also
um
flipping the bird to Murphy's lose
basically so you will know you know that
something at some point will go wrong in
your system
it's sure it's absolutely certain so
what you do against that is you playing
for it you plan to fail safe you test
before you use it and you monitor
regularly UA your AI system to be sure
everything is still working all right
again
um
there is a lot of possible thing here to
do and for good practice
yeah you need testing on more complete
testing um
the writing test plan getting usage
scenario don't
all of that can be helpful
so I know a lot of people are not
familiar with the tools that are
available there
uh if you use a python for unit testing
you will probably be equal the library
called the pie test and unit test
for the versioning tool that will help
you get your code up to date
um you have GitHub git is the most
common one bit by git by bucket or over
until available
uh this tool
tend to allow plugin for continuous
development and continuous integration
there is quite a few toolk in pi data or
during this few day where you will have
more information about that
and uh to create scenario that can be
read by everyone in the company I would
suggest you have a look at the
behavior-driven development
which tend to put
um
they have language which is not fully
programmation language but
pseudo-programation it kind of put thing
in order and help communicate
again help with your QA and check the
iso to follow
um 42 000 to 15 to help
uh you for usability
so
you have created the use of the AI
system what for
what how does it fit the problem is it
interpretable
is it easy to set up
is it stable to be used
is it easy to be modified
all of those condition duration is what
came into usability
and you want your system to be used so
you have to be careful of that so that
other people can use your system and not
just you in front of your local computer
rule of thumb here is to prefer
practical over fancy and to keep it
simple until you can't
doesn't mean complex is bad it means
that if you have the choice between
simple and complex
simple tend to come with advantage in
terms of testing reliability and
stability
so the example from our red line to a
choice we have done or considering the
usability
you have
you have seen that we create sequences
of images
the input from four of those sequences
Choice the guide for food sequences
oh I've been a image guide and we choose
that over a text guide for several
reasons
first because uh that way we can
directly use the embedder
the the embedded Vector we don't have to
translate that into language
um also because
we are completely independent on
language that way we don't need English
or French or Spanish or whatever it just
images
so it came with the inconvenient too uh
it's not very practical
um we can't use directly pre-training
classifier which rely on language
and that affects the ux and the
platformer architecture
so to come back with relationship you
have to communicate with the ux lead to
see if it's possible and how it's
possible to do it with the system
marketed
we have also done another Choice toward
usability
is
um at first
we have split the model into product
category
for example we use one model for the
codes and shirts and tops in general and
another one for the shoes
um we were able to do that because the
model and the metadata were already
versioned so it's not too much extra
effort and because we add the product
category as raw data so it was also
quick to access
even if it requires a bit of cleaning
but not too bad and the advantage we get
out of it is we have a more accurate
result for bootstrap
so what I mean by a bootstrap on by the
letter L for life cycle is you have to
take into consideration that the data
you have available and the data route
will be available change over time
so you have to consider the start of the
project where you will have to do with
the data you have in the end and the
continuation of the project where you
will have incoming data coming back and
improving the model hopefully
so it's a bit different from the
evolution of the project itself because
we are not talking about new feature or
new
um project inside the project it's
really taking into a convert so that I
will change so your model will have to
change too
and as I say for bootstrap we have made
the choice of doing some small model
badly trained but better than random
and for feedback how we coded that
is uh once the sequence have been given
to the end user we have the rest of the
platform this user was able to correct
or to validate the sequence
and giving a bad bad feedback to them
better we can group together the images
first on making it on cluster or we we
add vqi
it's um
basically it's not one Condor that use a
vector on
a discrete Vector as a base so we can
use that as this effect or for example
and that was the feedback loop
and also we had an over feedback loop
incoming from new images from the brands
that we also feed into the embedder
so a for assessing
um the checklist is here to assess what
is present it's not really here to
um give you order or give you
um the next thing you have to do it's
very to see what is currently happening
so yeah from time to time use it again
take bearings
it's uh
and also plan the next assessment once
every time you do an assessment
not to forget the things
and this assessment on
it will help you define the what you
have done well what you have done not so
well and it will help you define what
you need to do next
in agile method usually you do that sort
of assessment
every every Sprint that's kind of the
natural briefing point
and you want to do them regularly not to
be lost
and for the final letter neatness
when you are assessing on one of the
parameters we have to talk about
the field you must get is a feel of yes
it's a sort of mathematical Elegance
the results so over in the matner dino
here so yeah this one the filofish
efficiency and if you don't get that
feel from what you just have checked you
are probably in front of your risk
to
um detail a bit more
give a bit more detail into that
uh yeah neatness generally don't occur
into project I think we can all agree to
that
um
this list this checklist it will not
tell you what to do but it will
definitely pinpoint what is likely to go
very wrong
so it is the project vision is not neat
your risky project abundant because you
don't have the general direction
if the usability is not need you're
probably in front of the design depth if
the testing is not needed it's probably
a tech depth it's the organization is
not need you're probably facing your
knowledge legally risk
and all of that for all the point we
have seen before
so yeah I was a bit quicker than I
expected so there is plenty of time for
a question or give for me to give more
detail into something if you want
that's it
hi uh hi I'm Morgan uh my name is Chong
I'm taking off from tomorrow as a
moderate thank you very much for the
very nice talk I like the analogy that
you use in an article sense to direct
the data science hitting so let's let's
try and see if there's any questions in
in the chat and I will I will just bring
them up on the screen so that you can
answer that is that fine
all right uh all right there's the first
question here from uh just deep Singh or
bring it up on the screen so you can see
it Justice is asking thank you for the
presentation Morgan can you talk a
little bit more about life cycle
yes
so life cycle uh when you do a data
science project you usually have data
some sort of model or system Ai and data
coming out
so data coming in and the data coming
out will vary with time when you start
to project and if it happened for
example with that client there were
plenty of data but there were
no specific order in them so we had to
select a few first and see what happened
and when you do that selection you don't
have access to all the data possible you
honestly have access to part of the data
for example they were telling me they
were telling us so that they want to add
um
Booky project product at some point but
for now they will yet close and
instinctively the model for body product
and the model for clothes because we
were
Booth checking so sort of object and the
position of the object
is going to be very very difficult to
put in place so that's why I was yeah
this is not gonna work really so for now
let's uh check on one model per product
I know it's doable within the platform
usability and we will see after that how
it will evolve and hopefully we will be
able to gather the model to give
but
um I already know at the start of the
project that I don't get all the data
yet
and that often that poker
so you have to bootstrap with something
and here it was a it was a model but uh
as in the talk of Jana yesterday uh if
your first version is Rule based on
anything else it's a perfectly valid
bootstrap too
if it worked it worked
yeah absolutely I like the uh
methodology of of kiss
um that sometimes is the solution to
keep it simple
all right excellent
um uh great thanks for that very nice
very nice answer
um life cycle I'm looking through a
couple of questions there aren't any
just yet but if I may I would like to
ask one question of my own since I'm
also a data scientist
um
as a particular tool which is actually a
question that that some someone has
asked as well so I'll just bring it out
by Alejandro how do you choose what
tools to use and which project is
related to my question
so I'm in a consulting company usually
whatever the client of is the best
answer uh which means I don't always get
to choose
so uh that's why I'm more focused on
processes than tools because um
processes can be adapted to different
tools world
and from the tools you can get the
pattern of the process you need to use
so